[Music]
so welcome all it's great to see some in
people being hair and when look at
sunrise city hall sadistic really
great fun you like it for giving the stick
he knew can it alka bad briefly builds
what the work is the time to us this
scientist for the series and after that
real time to agree top-youtuber views
yes called practical cases 11 we
have already replying day the science of
open source for the series
and so is willy kind about the city of
amsterdam the organization and how to get there
15,000
and growing civil service and working
for the series
after the all this site is i think they
view 100 we did engineer and the role
team
mf 120,000 inhabitants in the city and
visitor center is making it really
interesting place to work
the problem emotion mouth  so far from the
step expedition just a few he
basketing you important would
sustainability'
that sorma I always himself inclusive
he also wants more with the slayer mobility
yes
chains again or a mission cars
b  efore 20 eur ides can out who
sells this and again hoping to be able to
help talk with smart technologies
how to live an elephant in trial
billet i disagree fake and coming we white
pearl
so hope you van marwijk sensualist
and less and for simple  the is it becomes
houses in the series is like a something
you want to help this is an example my
collection wow is users you can
choose there is liner us but you can choose the
studio live dial in some people can get
some people kent
which can help  you choose in
democracy had serious control over
their inner city hall grammy now it is leaking
a game on white guidelines and how i am
to work we did and this is the tadaa
manifest
this is bbq sex points that we because i
mainly do projects at first  one is
that fierce cb incl wie wanten taking
place in the difference
2 people
and of course ebitda legal
the second one s mee want people to be in
control of what we do it there we
live in alteveer temporarily u de people
just to eat offers legitimate and
manager at open transparent and from
everyone for everyone
zo if you see this is really well bit
freek concepts itenc
open source zo is the team you will i
want to work s open source door project
opensource
this is now with possible  because wie
sundancer really privacy
sense to detail and models for
predicting from a problem not really
easy to make open source cache in
February knows how you're the technique
criminals
than the program to their work but
definitely
met bing transparente stuff import and
specially when you  're making choices for
temple weer summer die is bing santas
cool your mouth gateway to explain why this
choice as mentink mekking de source code
open glasses that help you this and other
problems with technology works if it's
yes scalable
if i can apply worldwide de problems
with amsterdam is that is charlie and small
part of the world
so effe effe city in the world i fell
down technical problem you know
ju  llie moe for the party
so will be open source we hope to be able
to work together we that the series and
communities like this
anyway the two cases we can do this too
you to you about
the fryslân is woman things monitoring
service requests ekkerman is something
we do  with computer vision and family in the
middle of what we do for
this game if you wife who party
drivers attend scouting serious
request
what is a service orchestra base gray samy
kamkar website door color phone numbers
and tell them fascination fledgeby's
this might seem really  simple but this
hanover 2015 thousand request shirley such
a sunday's wie f12 of the glass
champion really great thing of beep
industry therapy king's design things
of sammy chelsea bridge at both go to
fast boot beg you with your nose
there is 20 time
garbage minecraft to  be able to the tact
so that they complicated to share some
examples of
over the nineties different categories we
him so long so people a contain  er
before continuing chunks
bridge timfit bridgers the flat
category
again for weeds and that's
basically in a hall and how you got it rules
for how many words can be on your side
balk and vs gave my real make sure that
there is not too much there  something about the
cyborgs who do you have that whole toe
detective somebody stalking mat wietske
cycles stays your clean desk so yes we
dance and moss
and that chem-dry in the public
space who do you have a fix-on the image
id tag me  sometimes
sql to fix
so was leak the old fashioned correct samba
director i lose earth with
we'll just get it things being
selected
something parents like garbage from my house
outside kennedy clean juice has disco
study banking corey rich and like op
dick garbage  gringoire like needs
calling cars pickup want you be
pull couch
what you that is not really work well so
this is in fact if you go get much more
mission the cash wheel drive twice people
not be happy
zo  we looking for ways to be effectively
i tab off those texts and service request
back so that it's in bed basically
it's really simple textual classifier
trains on a ladder
i had week number before so there is a
d'actions surfer the did was and  that the
models become their docs that is so there
is a is experiencing a boat is doing something there
is about
at wilec tweets about some january 10
show let's go quiet dating about
the fun time to produce an the water with
i don't know  is able to detect so
something like piringen covers speeding
and nature harmony dutch people ham
not the translate
and what is six now is there is about going
to face with your let music and we are
able to just really
this act be this bout and see
keep  your router righty partner
so we also for simple
physicists families a there is garbage an
extra container
wesley because of the use and set
show model
then bring the kinds they do we know
it's about how she reads
dizlayki you still don't  know for sure zo
weer working on implementing like the
also application or
smart interfaces which is tested by the
what up be so this is 16 click
under ipod so so this is the moment
in the series by numbers of using this for
there is 22.000 is you  hear
blekinge tears heretical city
to clean up
the public space and that would be for
and all or
nothing  act met samadhi is
complaining about about minutes know
what sort of boat to be able to know
what sort of the park my two cents
would de goal of this project is to make
it easier to report issues de router
more effectively and adding wel relevant
information to the report also memang
most
moleeds push i be sweet ability of
the city for clean streets figures
reach
et cetera
yes je future work some of this is
already done but cinematic bij
implementati  e the organization numbers
wheelie this charred in organization at
city of amsterdam
what your squad an ice cream kind of ideas and
working at dda is all this so who cares
about that willy happy to do the
things one of the sith implementing the
text now public something  wits xlii and yes there
is not there an example for us and won
jurgen and narrower ex series chain it
implemented hopefully things you want that
tag deep kids in these reports
is belly 15% carriage figures for 5 million
euros she is here so so you  is quite
simple application bad the potential so
youtube has to force people container outside
santing neat twice you mean
twins and doing it better get more
information
as if you even more multimodal glass
vario [ __ ] we also the tag like the
after all essence what surfing garbage van
der giessen  to increase the usa of the
further
something as we're trying to see if it's
valuable and reporting with computer
vision pretzels techniques picture and
the tact in de trap  me
and for santing seem never complete
this is mostly impossible
for smelt boot is the irish dress when
i see it the boot
cbs researching if this valuable
addition to reach more people with curly
level other people that know how to make
report u the series on it  izar cublight
in pacific no brother more people dat
well from the khandaq the series and the
thumbnail boots the people were not
present so kees seem in the coalition in
its margin help you get the tokens
where you live and the ultimate goal is to
prevent it is  reports and tea recipes
city run spanking clean all your want zo
bit more the technical background the
reborn pair is the best performing
monissen tfsi fr de logistics aggression
how you de love deep learning bells
that's a dive perform on this day the set
en de for the  deployment intersystems
you simplify flush epia de hold back
the have the backbone system
would greetings the interface is all
connected to django good to we users
but me and lak  in a cl the
producers who of that parliament
and who do we have here model together the
roof already there the garden jtd ref
use to build half a million search' quest
sharer of rolls systems and encourage
people gathering
new share and here sometimes left so
lights will be  shared basically the the
source code of the application of the
classifier pray for post or i play
content working severin
interesting with you can fun than
this is if you decide to stink one day
projects that vibrate
if the show its open source can
be  used to quickly make something they
were looking for ways to real time
monitor
the sir success queen she has you in
with you like so call center
the syringe dan 15 people working girl dee
and manager neatest looking
is it going well i get no eddy zoëy
muddle  iq van maglite quick real-time
dashboard
could you can syrah so how will the in this
is basically this is it to call super
budget like
is wil decks and you can just use or scp
items and dede  n then she via the one thing
which at and epa in an iq test experts
information and send it is said it was
like and f10 of work in the still using
it still running king throne zo tip
for this tool
enquiries adjusted to its willy of
enthusiastic  and quickly mix of bio-time
dashboard you can show and screens
youssef your profile is a public tions
so for simple this was studay this
morning who sends the time series
covered
2d problem youth gonna be for the
savety with this is the coming weeks  would you
man this always busy book for some
reason of money
people reporting
problem because they cinque dan work in
the weekends with who do you do this so low
ok and this is pike u can you
enthusiastic big bellies
this is another down dan wel will do
i would like to share bit for
using a beauty fashion today
jack garbage on the streets excuse is
not perfect your business on the
debit side of 1000 object would
processing the bkd the set is is
already
wie tan  k user boom becomes winter this
is basically start experiment in whitby
is a computer vision on the sides and
government
coasters can bison legal issues we so
how i think bios men start doing this
and see what's reaction again can we
frank cameras
what people be  happy outdoor play people
with an advice api about this can be
assured privacy law projects like this
and what expression to sniff people
once again who live there and the idea the
sets and make the small gray doubly
w2p for and the aging and used on
yourselfs
again  public relations on which I share the
green ice
high quality sets and
charlie's openly and als they experiments
team which use case you used use cases
and eventually i use this to increase
the ability and sustainability
your piece quick overview of what we haven'  t
now wants to do planning again
like a cell about 1000 and means
object
really simple more see an intense
flow president and imagenet becomes
qu  ite well we do want it to work
better be able to take more this with
abject
zo weer hoop en tnt de d so he the
fifty thousand immetjes
this realization make this public knows help
chain the batmobile possible and were
also working together with 43 m students
keddah infrastructure going descaver [ __ ]
i was a single love one pc
streaming this coming from there four goals
kan die for more games
this is a demo that
special i really vision zero point
shiro-an of it count collections
networking yes with were looking for
ways to effectively and
met location of closet be able to account
de karmi's most de streets of i can
make it and use this to blend cars
drive and so forth temple detecting the
different ipod stress is relevant if you
know where washing machines of garbage
becky trainees  center right vehicles to
great location
more effectively drive flash us less
energy and clean up in a way that more
sustainable and other
than a  t my iphone be
nice
then get out of bed and christ can de bie
interiors problem pff
yourself driving cars everywhere and
scanning for other cars and hope in
recognition of paulus in the series a
week and fix problems faster
yes would paspel implementations asset
reporting something to was  with us using
I would take you then tv from the type
who does what and when the van trucks
problem you know this one this is
driving grange scanning carson sie
were park who is want is the right cm
camera 2 die tact
tradition in the audience award  another man
this is how sr connects each valid in the
speed camera in english
speed camera summary in dutch fashion show
of your smelt
love you care taker der ham for
spinning wheel and to measure 17 and for
garbage area garbage an external
container
the scar picture of you  and you can
there still some discussion white legal
department if this is okay but we want
to say it's possible and some relaxing
sardes public the cool experiment yes
so the man were working on right now
help hopefully in the next few months we're
going to watch the videos view
reden collection of the pipeline ready
with this can't be deferred experiment
with your scarab
expression great to 11 de was 16 cameras in
frame
sophie kamp  racist images bio-time
think week has a correct infrastructure
or two
drivers that window and how does such a
na is the video
typical watch you see this and i want
to use the real time
you want a controller fleet of garbage
truck
so it i  work sorry I miss grease
but no fascinates him now effectively and at home
or corps succeed
yes you must have been working on all those
14.000 garbage containers in front of
house and hit with nicky velor
management power supply sensors in those two ways
than their full
would who I had  the cities real time
your audience met he seemed the siphon
publicly available
the pan met this is for example
your one century that swing the container
that is just detective fix blocked would you
flew t  he beginning leather patch is in
the pudding in the cards and i will say
it's not feel with sammy channel cool
product leftover it is also ensures you
want to combine adele sevilla even truck
driving at the incident is blocked
the even more details on je well ja  that
stuff dragonfly idea how
true women standing next u the app will
be able to detail with the text in this
for fun series
join that in future it you have 10 june
out there loos videos of people jumping
it in the containers for training day
days  would you the future for this early
culture bed would a two experiment the
applications to see what's possible
camus this will use vol and the present
light idea the set make this bar look and
if we make them all open source
i had to it is an already  studies all
around the world and whoever oil can use
their models
darcy die it is so and then
gifts but I think it is a collection
of yes thank you
yes and and cancer cell is such a vim keeps
the party time working on its ab  out each
purpose housing falls investigation this
morning we build our brains french in
the banking system and it's free avast
en dan de game is bizarre free the
looking for what can be do what do you
what to do yes
so this is the first exploration of laptop
i am very holt and relephant on i lady
believe something in the peppers and oh so for the
nam
touch people you have at home on house
in your app social housing system der
corporations is
kind of see my
the mire public and then you hef de
lip-rol housing and the eleventh the public
housing something
the social singing cheaper bits already so
quite easy to for at mood is if so that
's a test in die garble how did you have this
for home or so who did I run
legal subnets team so before  sample grant
this for ferry loop rights and you just
be granted to someone else for normal
price and you earn money we have this
new something
long-term vacancy you have to
thinkwise you need the bed ex ii it have a squad
love for simple if you  when  t to move back
to another country
bit stil bantu hef
certain income oh you want to have the
security of care in holland's
jungsheft' orphan adwords would je keep
your house a bit don't laugh and
eating lizzie en nobody living in te
wit en juf  other times of an alright
active duty
blythe works prostitution and staff or
that lets him a categories and the
look at what doe investigates the
municipality
is mini legal hotels mainly it
was solid focus points minute game
for the last few years mean so der sun
vacancy you  prostitution
turkish yes zo the letter the goal of this
project is to see how can i help the
in force mens dyke the housing
forever in force my first name
dr necklace is i call mostly from an ex
of foam and neighbor how thinking that
person is billy  doing something they
should contact you they contacts municipalité
enrico reload er zo be one to support
them to increased efficiency and
effectiveness because this is a very
labor  -intensive job to do to decrease
housing error en indiana you have
per project housing for ever run into the
games team zo for well budget is i now
there is a learning tool a lot of quotation the
look at who is this house
ben-day doezum manual power  t sation
not really animal stinking ok this
looks quite good times king for this
sick neubert now they go to the house en
doe en miss faction very of the day
after go back 0 2 times crispy porn at
home and then you can just do
ja je  can to anything and then there is
a third and final conclusion so what do
you do for it chase
first of all you could s the tassel
douiri heft you know who is for someone
yes then message and mixed-signal could
be already see some cases die voor  so
i never most [ __ ]' sample of twenty
people living in a house you should sony
for the square meters
you could about that say that looks greedy
weert let's check it out
so who lives there is one also you know apps
to all made the french i  still know who
wil
place make the case more in forms
sonar enforcement is there qua car loan to
the games qype in informs you want to
give them more information about the
property
about the people de historie stavlak
that's zo deken ya know what to expect
and how to handle
damn i also want to prioritize
beddoes wie [ __ ] en wie younger you see
it certain cases of
way more interesting to look at
something like this should be good to focus on those
jesus en wie or zo want to tell them and
explained and by those case is  chicken white
is your high
chance of joke so they do ja
wiser i put a lever and who is
mainly soda de de housing the part of
the municipality
brain parts put this i was made
for processing de ja
new way of working between and sword of
decorate in how they work which cases
they looked into any viewer for altorf
they weren't and what tape or pedigree
had about so who u stand and them busy for
mobile to look at history cases and see
ya [ __ ]
what what nothing especially the  mwf bach die
zo this one is not be available because
it's very private
wwf bach this is public label is cool
or
yes directory sticks on the house danny sms
betty script airbnb share for well who
not doing anything how this big beer
train to see if it can help 6 predicting
beach houses ar woods taboo grass and the
poland crime who has misia listing the
three kill you  exact address so
the matching is the problem with
looking into that now we the student or
something then you need more information
about
the people living the address hang neck
how many people is it and family what is
the black power that theoretical trading
die  defarge chris second round the one
sorry steve very fresh yes so it pulls
you know how you got information about the
pap it's so so so such a man us other
houses or other properties and who effect
graded eerebout de neighborh  ood so is the
ferry popular no protected from tourist
outdoor life study appreciate all
problem flightcheck grade it en
neighborhood dh would this mobile base or
the moodle who is
yes well training and this will look
something like funda bad en wit knew
something for at listing  snot would find them
for the ai who will be the same and in
this will help the desert and forth mens
juice yes to it listing someone to
focus and if you click on a listing
you see more information and yes moors
coming up such a bloodbath  do he
already has it pricing at ik such a need and he
design it not really good because it
would be the beast super tco provide
privacy by design and then blood co2
ladders light so beer is a furry is
yes in this his very interesting project
with ditzo very private der sloof private
eye dea in will follow soon who is careful
about this and we're working for simple
we choose the student
he is full more
abstract and peak corpse Maartje step
by corpse
transparency h  et keeps that xlii
imperia public the project how can you
apply bed and what can you do and they did
scientist'
to make sure the do so de right whale
zoey even master student eaj how is
queen te dit this and help help is to
make it  more i won and our
oil import an allergy
in this project is the inch there fun and
how that sometimes conflict with the
complex 10 you wanted you for your
mobile for this case
the everywhere in turbo within typical
importance for i can see if the  algorithm
is transparent is the [ __ ] that argue so
the intro tries it whether a single case
is important so blew that that
specific is pop-up and what is it des
études our involvement would you ever seem
this is the moor
yes i think here onno this  picture and he
drank you that seems so see it and the
second or with der is for show more
effort you after pudding to it to make
it in turbo bol of you go into more
complex models for now we're using
random breast and wie er  using several
time to  see how can we make it and
purple and if you're interested in the
priest kan then adwords house
yes he who looks like it is already built on me
but you will be dept
zo so earth first reasult so engineer
now do and force my mission in sum of
half of the cases
there was xlii housing for all together
a half it was a public de moodle
het precision there is the squad important
something oil doesn't cost your go-to we house and
something kassel of time en zo money
so who should really like  to see that the
position is quite course and you see it
looks like something seven that for percent so for
now it's quite good and murphy lily in
september will be there again
from the pilot and risks how the
addresses and see the actual
reasult speakers is to  stil yes
pri looking for to see how this works in
the real life
ok so what we dress corpse case is he
hope you will remember why not big
brother
this feels bit like that and this education
it inline who has u balk and she
minutes pallet ie  who you open with
he kitty of any yogis in via internet
can to as if you're left ideals of new
project in this mather
like the sky help us is talcum powders
and yes he hope you enjoyed and this is your
congo then don't have who happy birthday
in data lab
there if they do you can explore the
dna point to and student als nl
en yes thank you if there any questions
I discuss class time
[Applause]